you sacrificed yourself for me
[Music]
I won't let anything happen to her Anna
is by far one of the best Disney
Princesses of all time but what will
happen to her after frozen - we've
imagined it all from marriage to kids to
reunions with long-lost family members
this is so nice I wish it could be like
this all the time we were so pleased to
see that Anna and Kristoff are still
together in the trailers for frozen - so
it's pretty safe to assume that these
two are going to get their happy ever
after in recent years Disney hasn't
included as many wedding scenes in the
princess movies so it's unlikely we'll
get to see on and Kristoff get hitched
on the big screen but we're confident
they'll tie the knot eventually of
course
Elsa spun and Olaf would be at their
ceremony but who else would make the
guest list given that we see Rapunzel
and Eugene at Elsa's coronation we are
confident they do Ana's big day
eagle-eyed fans also spotted Cinderella
and tiana at Elsa's coronation so we'd
like to think that those princesses
would be invited too
speaking of Rapunzel we believe she'd
have a big part to play in Ana's future
after frozen - there's a theory that
Rapunzel is cousins with Anna and Elsa
it's also thought that Elsa and Ana's
parents might have been on their way to
Rapunzel and Eugene's wedding when they
got shipwrecked the shipwreck happened
three years earlier which is when
tangled was released plus Elson Rapunzel
both possess unusual powers so there's
plenty of links between the kingdom of
arendelle and the kingdom of Corona and
we think that on and Kristoff would
spend lots of time with Rapunzel and
Eugene they have similar personalities
so we'd reckon they'd really hit it off
and go on lots of double dates and when
each couple has kids their little ones
would play together all the time we
definitely see kids in Ana's future and
at least two if not more after all she
felt so lonely growing up without Elsa's
company that it would be unlikely for
onit to have an only child talented fans
have even pictured went on and
Christoph's little
would look like you're essentially many
versions of their parents so adorable we
think they'd be surrounded by herds of
reindeer too in fact the first frozen to
trailer might have also given us a
glimpse of on and Christoph's kids there
is speculation that the mystery girl and
boy in the leaves are actually this
couples offspring the girl looks kind of
similar to Anna while the boy with the
blond hair totally reminds us of
Kristoff would they be their children
another theory suggests it's actually a
flashback to win on his mom was a child
and possibly her dad too there are
theories that clean I do know and King
Agner are actually still alive and
didn't perish in the shipwreck if that's
the case then we would love on its
future to involve a reconciliation with
her folks could Anna and Kristoff also
reconcile with his parents Kristoff
believes he's an orphan
but there's a theory that his parents
are actually still alive and that he was
taken by the trolls when he was just a
kid in chandni V in folklore there are
stories of trolls taking children so
it's not beyond the realms of
possibility
another theory put forward by the movies
director Chris buck claims that I do
none I ignore had a son on board the
ship the trio ended up on an island and
the boy grew up to be none other than
Tarzan Chris buck was really just having
a bit of fun with that one connecting
different movies inside one Disney
Universe but if it really were the case
then that would make Tarzan on an Elsa's
little brother
so we would definitely want to see on a
meeting up with her long-lost siblings
after frozen - we know how important
family is to Anna she was willing to
sacrifice herself to save her sister and
in the second trailer for frozen - we
here are natok about Elsa - pabbie I
won't let anything happen to her
so Ana's future would definitely involve
being surrounded by her relatives
particularly Elsa although Anna might
very well leave arendelle with Kristoff
to set up home somewhere else she
wouldn't meet up with her big sis on the
weekly we're not given any proof that
Elsa gets a partner but we like to think
that she does eventually find someone
special to share her life with
on
else's kids would be such close cousins
just imagine if else's child inherited
her ice powers Elsa would handle that
situation a lot better than her own
parents did conceive it
she wouldn't without a pair of gloves
until her child not to feel she teach
her little one to control it so that
Ana's kids would be safe from harm we
would not want to see a repeat
performance of accidental ice strikes
with the next generation on the subject
of powers were excited to discover
whether Ana has any of her own the
magical fire in the frozen two trailers
has led to the theory that Ana has fire
powers this would be the perfect
counterbalance to Elsa's ice powers we'd
love to see how Ana would use those
powers in her future perhaps she would
help communities that are struggling to
make ends meet due to freezing
temperatures so that's a wrap on what
happens to Ana
after frozen - what do you think will
happen to her let us know in the
comments make sure to subscribe to the
things for more videos like this one and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up thanks for watching see ya
[Music]